يتم منح تصريح امني بموجبها
وهناك جهود حثاثه تتعلق بمعالجه تلك
المعلومات السريه واعطائي التصاريح
الامنيه المطلوبه للموظفين تتم بطريقه
مدروسه بالعوده لسؤالي كلها يجب علينا ان
نتوكل حذر الان
التكهن او التخمين حول ما قد يكونوا خلف
ما يبدو بانه تسريب محتمل لمعلومات سريه
لابد من اجراء عمليه
حسب الاصول هل تتحدثون عن ان هناك
تمت تسريب قد حدث من قبل لشخص ما
انتم
سمحتم عن هذا الامر قبل يومين
وسوف تتولى وزاره العدل العامه للاهاب
والتحقيق بالامر مره اخرى
ورغم ما قيل فان وزاره الدفاع قد ذكرت
بانها تنظر الى مساله توزيع قدره الوصول
لهذه المعلومات واجراء تغييرات اداريه
لديهم
الكم الاكبر من هذه المسندات لكن لابد لنا
ان نعلم ما الذي حدث وهذا الامر قد تتولى
وزاره العدل النظر فيه هل لديكم اي فكره
عن عدد الاشخاص الذين كان لهم قدره الوصول
لهذه المعلومات
هل هناك المئات نظرا لهذا التسريب تسريب
المستندات فان
الولايات المتحده قد تخسروا معركتها سواء
مع
القراصنه او مع اي شخص يرغبه بمعرفه اي
معلومات حولنا الرئيس قد تمت احاطته هذا
حول هذا الامر
ويتم النظر فيه بصوره جاده من خلال الجهود
التي يتم بحثها والنظر في التداعيات
الامنيه التي قد تنبع عن هذا الامر ووزاره
العدل تتولى اداره تحقيق جنائي ناخذ هذا
الامر على محمل الجد
وامام من اعذار مقبوله لمثل هذه المسندات
التي يتم تسريبها فهي لا يجب ان تكون في
متاحه للعامه
اذا ما كان هناك تمت اجراء يجب اتخاذه
فكلما نعلم عن النطاق ما حدث من هذا من
تسريب المستندات فسوف نتخذ الخطه من على
ذلك
هل اتحدث الرئيس بايدن مع نظيره
الرئيسكي حول تسريب تلك المستندات وحول
سلامه المعلومات المسؤولون الامريكيون
كانوا على اتصالا مع نظرائهم وحلفائهم
خلال الايام القليله الماضيه
هل نتحدث عن
مساله التسريب المستندات ام ام فقط
معلومات اخرى قد تم
تسريبها لاشخاص وقام هؤلاء بالتلاعب بها
وتغيير طبيعتها لا اعلم اذا ما كنا قد
وصلنا الى هذا الامر لكن في بعض الحالات
على الاقل فان المعلومات التي تم نشرها
عبر الشبكه قد تم تغييرها مما هي عليه في
مصدرها الاصلي هذا ما استطيع ان اخبركم به
وكيف
ولا نعلم كيف حدث هذا الامر لكننا نسعى
لفهم ما حدث بصوره دقيقه
وبالعوده لنقطتك فاننا نهيب بكم جميعا ان
تتوخوا الحذر حول كيفيه سرد القصص الصحفيه
بشان هذه المعلومات المسربه سؤالان
السؤال الاول حول الصين ذكرتم ان ذلك كان
رد فعل قد يكون او رد فعل مبالغا فيه من
قبل الصين الى اي حد انتم واثقون بانهم ما
من ردود افعال اخرى قد تنبع من طرف الصين
وقد تدفع للصراع
كنا قد تحدثنا على
مخاوف في اندلاع صراع ولكن المواجهه قد
تكون قائمه ولكن ليس من جزء سياستنا ان
تتجه الامور الى هذا النحو لكن ليس
مستغربا لرئيسه تايوان ان تزور الولايات
المتحده وما نامل من ان يحدث في المرحله
اللاحقه هو تخفيض
منسوب التوتر والاستمرار في التواصل مع
الصين والعمل حول
اجراء زياره للوزيره الهدف منها الدالغه
كله هو ان نعمل على اقامه خطوط خطوط
اتصالا اضافيه بعد زياره بيلوسي لان هناك
جمله من المسائل وكان سوف يتجه الوزير
البلنكن للحديث والتطرق بمسائل التغير
المناخي السؤال اخر حول المستندات هل كانت
اي من تلك المستندات التي تسريبها قد قوضت
الجهود
الراميه لدعم اوكرانيا ثانيا اولئك الذين
القائمون على
سريتي ومسؤوليتي تلك المستندات كان قدموا
ضمانات بان لن تتم قرص القرص قرصنتنا او
اجراء ايقظنا هل يمكن الحكومه ان تقوم
بعرقله اي محاوله من هذا النوع في
المستقبل فيما يخص علاقتنا مع اوكرانيا
لن تتغير وانا لن اتحدث عن اي مستند بعينه
سوف اتحدث عن المعلومات الاستخباراتيه
سؤالك كان حول اذا ما كان هناك اي اثر على
دعم اوكرانيا فسوف نستمر في دعم اوكرانيا
كما قال الرئيس مهما استغرق الامر من زمن
هو بالنسبه لموضوع
التقنيه التصدي الى القرصنه لا اعلم لا
يمكننا الحديث عن هذا
البيت الابيض والذي تركز طبعا على موضوع
تسريب الوثائق الوثائق البانتاجون لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات